foreign
up on FYI three months on from the
powerful earthquakes in Syria and turkey
thousands of children remain homeless we
have an exclusive report
and Dr range gives us advice on how to
look after our mental health sometimes
we forget that actually you can be
whoever you want to be
[Music]
hello this is your Weekly News show FYI
not only do we have info on the latest
news here you also get the chance to
report on your own stories and may marks
three months since the really powerful
earthquakes in turkey and Syria so we
have an exclusive report from the
children who were affected there
hundreds of buildings were destroyed in
both countries millions of families and
children were left homeless with limited
access to essential supplies like water
and Medicine
huge tented camps have been set up by
Charities as well as shelter these camps
provide food clothes and children can go
to school there is also support to help
children cope with what they've
experienced
an FYI film crew went to gaziantep in
Turkey so some of the children living in
these camps could share their story and
report on what their lives have been
like three months on from the
devastating earthquakes
[Music]
6th February 2023
turkey and Syria were hit with powerful
earthquakes
1.5 million people became homeless
[Music]
when the earthquake happened we were
trapped with my mum because the Wardrobe
had blocked the door
[Music]
organ that day the sounds coming from
the outside screens window shatterings
and curtains flying out
[Music]
when I wake up I thought it was a dream
I looked around and there was Rubble
everywhere
I was very frightened during the
earthquake and very sad when I found out
my school was closed
foreign
[Music]
I feel safe here there is warm food and
somewhere to play there's some other
coins allowed
I named
when the earthquake happened we were
trapped with my mum or the then the
second earthquake happened
which unblocked the door and we escaped
I chilled up yeah
I do not think something like this could
happen the next day I said I need to
wake up but it was not a dream
everything was really scary I could
still feel the aftershocks and we found
it very hard to get a place to stay my
friend from school died in the
earthquake it took a lot of time for the
rescue teams to get to our village
so they could not rescue my friends
my cousin took me downstairs
my mum brought out my sisters he got in
our car and waited for the earthquake to
be over
he stayed in the car for 10 days it was
really cold sleeping in the car when I
woke up I almost couldn't feel my feet
it was as if they were gone all of us
felt like that then we came here and
they gave us this tent
okay
we put our shoes there my mom cooks it
sometimes
this is where we keep our clothes
I have an uncle who sleeps there
we have two mattresses on top of one
another
let me show you
we spread them out as you can see
we have a heater here we keep it on so
it won't be too cold
please
[Music]
I generally go to the library school
park or the cafeteria there's so many
good books time goes by quickly there I
sometimes play chess with friends that's
fun
also going to school takes your mind off
the day of the earthquake when you focus
on other things we forget about that
thing the school helps me out with my
lessons but also my emotions so I really
like it there
okay
I really like my teachers because I have
been so nice to me since I came here and
even shared their food with me
so a bit odd when I first came here but
then I got used to it now I really like
my classmates and have a lot of fun with
them
my favorite game is tag because I run
very fast I'm really good at running
[Music]
we play table football and table tennis
and go to the park together which is fun
we don't have action-packed days but
we're still enjoying ourselves
foreign
we've called on John Sparks from the
children's charity UNICEF which is
helping people who've been left homeless
the children in the video look really
happy but is this going to be their
long-term home so they look happy now
but if we think about what they've been
through you know they've seen their
schools destroyed they've seen their
homes destroyed many of them will have
been separated from their families as
well and that's where it's really
important that we do things which are
seemingly normal like carry on with
their education
so three months on and families are
still really needing your help so how
long until they'll all have permanent
homes it's going to be a very long time
you know the destruction is huge so
UNICEF and other organizations will be
there for the long term and initially
it's a humanitarian response of drinking
water and vaccinations we're there to
support them and putting children right
at the center of planning for the
rebuilding of lives really well thank
you so much for joining us thank you so
Braden over to you so the UK government
promised to help out the people of
turkey in Syria after the earthquakes
but what exactly are we doing well this
is the forest secretary James cleverley
it's his job to deal with all the issues
abroad and Scarlett spoke to him for FYI
so in turkey and Syria and children are
still you know witnessing horrifying
effects from the earthquake that
happened and now apparently some kids
have become homeless so what are you
doing to help them well the situation in
uh in turkey and North Syria after the
earthquakes that we saw is was it was
terrible we deployed a search and rescue
team very very quickly we're going to
keep working with the Turkish
authorities uh to assess what more needs
to happen particularly on the
Reconstruction side of things and also
what we can do to make sure that if
there are future earthquakes they don't
have the same devastating effect for
more info on the earthquake and why they
happen just head to our webpage at
first.news forward slash FYI
coming up why do boys find it harder
than girls to talk about their feelings
and a prehistoric report from an FYI
News Club member I'm gonna see where the
UK's most famous dinosaur is moving to
hi jiffy
[Music]
so we all know that talking about our
feelings isn't always easy but a quick
look up online and you'll see loads of
surveys that show that boys find it a
lot harder to open up than girls but why
is that well we decided to look into it
with the help of Dr range an NHS doctor
and an expert in children's mental
health in his video boy's biggest
conversation Dr ranchhad from a group of
boys about the pressures they feel
growing up
foreign
[Music]
that's why I don't smell much I'm kind
of a skinny person it's obviously being
more muscly would be it would be
something I'd like
oh I wouldn't make money she's a sugar
mental but my Ginger here she really
likes it I don't my hair is very weird
like it's not black hair but it's not
white hair and it's not really any
racist just hair
Sports I think yeah my height so I want
to be a bit bigger but I know that can't
happen
and probably
was about a week
I don't know
well that's around just a book all about
this it's called how to be a boy and
he's joining us now hello thank you so
much for joining me so your book is
almost like a book guide through
childhood really isn't it and it's for
boys but can girls read it too there are
things in there that I think apply to
everybody things like discovering who
you are and celebrating that looking
after your body looking after your
mental well-being dealing with things
like bullying
um these are things that everyone goes
through so obviously a big topic is body
image I mean we get loads of questions
from FYI news club members and of course
we saw it earlier in the boy's biggest
conversation body image I mean some boys
just never feel like they're not good
enough actually boys think about body
image just as much as everyone else but
we don't get to talk about it you might
see pictures of how people are online or
on screen and think that you have to be
that way and that's not necessarily the
case I think that boys and young men
these days get bombarded with so many
messages about how they're supposed to
be and sometimes we forget that you can
be whoever you want to be and actually
when you're struggling it's really
important that you speak to somebody
about it so a relatable one that's
coming up at the moment for me I've got
my exams is Stress and Anxiety now how
do boys and girls cope with that kind of
stress when it comes to exam stress
specifically remember you're not alone
lots of people are in the same boat so
talk to each other you know get advice
and tips from each other help each other
out just as important as do spending
time on the learning is taking a break
having some time to yourself and if you
can do a bit of physical activity to
diffuse that stress boys can be quite
mean to each other and then try and make
it out like it was just a bit of banter
but really sometimes words can hurt and
if it carries on it can eventually lead
to bullying so what advice would you
give to people in that situation banter
isn't always harmless it's usually meant
in a joking way but it may not be
received like that and you're right if
it goes too far you're veering into
bullying territory and nobody wants to
end up there remember that if you're
being bullied it's never okay speak to
someone who can help you out and that
might be a responsible adult or a
grown-up a teacher or someone at home
let them know what you're going through
thank you very much for joining me
thanks for having me
foreign
check out this video that's been doing
the rounds online it supposedly shows a
newt quickly changing color but can it
be real
well the answer is no it's a fake
digitally altered video
[Music]
so Scarlet have you seen that a dinosaur
has been spotted moving from London to
Coventry that sounds like another fake
news story to me well actually dippy the
massive replica skeleton that used to be
in the Natural History Museum has now
made its move to its new home in
Coventry we sent an FYI News Club member
to meet it here's utterly's report
thank you
this is dippy the dip the docus there
are 292 bones and it's 26 meters long
that's twice as long as a bus
it was on display at the Natural History
Museum in London for 110 years but since
then dippy has become one of the most
traveled dinosaurs in recent history it
has already visited eight cities in the
UK while it was on tour two million
people came to say hi now it's my turn
to pay to visit in its new home in
Coventry hi Japan how was your journey
okay not up for talking I get it let's
talk to someone who is hi Lorraine if
you work at the Natural History Museum
so you must have seen how popular dippy
is what do you think is the secret of
dippy's popularity I think everyone
really loves the kind of story of
dinosaurs and how they lived all those
millions of years ago but look how big
they grew and how successful they were
at the time so I think there's always a
Fascination for them what's it like to
have such an important exhibit in
Coventry it's important because
Coventry isn't the most famous city ever
so really it's nice they've got
something really good a tourist
attraction what have you learned today
the diplos doculus is absolutely massive
I really like Devi's Tails because it
like wraps around and it looks like a
needle and it must be looking very hard
to not break when they discovered it I
think that's cool well I've learned that
it's a very nice dinosaur scene
dinosaurs have 86 more bones than human
body what's it like to have such an
important exhibit in commentary it's
really important because we've we had
city of culture during 2021 and now
having probably the most famous dinosaur
in the UK for three years is just
brilliant
[Music]
thanks otterly if you have a story and
want to report for FYI why not set up an
FY news club at your school for more
information head to our webpage at
first.new FYI see you next time bye
[Music]